when we were at the way structures we
went to looked at leadership and and
what's interesting about leadership is
it it's the subject most open to hot air
basically because in the end
leadership's like it's like that all
definition of pornography as it's very
difficult to define but you know it when
you see it and leadership tends to be
the same thing and sometimes you get
leaders themselves trying to write
leader books about leadership which
often end up being somewhat embarrassing
you get attempts where people get back
and they look at Alexander the Great or
they look at some historical figure and
try and draw great great great lessons
for it on the whole I tend to still
think that the extent that most business
is about ideas and change is that either
the person who's leading the company has
got to be a great source of ideas and
change themselves and that applies to
particular companies or else they've got
to have the ability to bring that out in
other people and those two things go
together and if you sometimes people can
go too far in that direction you've
definitely got to have the sort of
managerial clout to make things work and
that's a sort of given i think you know
or at least you would have people around
you who know how to do it but you look
at the sort of business people who
really changed industries you look at
Bill Gates or Rupert Murdoch there is
there is it isn't as an urgency there's
a restlessness about them which and and
and sort of interest in what what on
earth's going on out there which I think
does have an effect if you want an
example I think you can see that with
gates a bit with philanthropy you have
this Restless clever person you know
who's always asking why not why can't we
do this and in a good okie when it hit
things like antitrust you hungry perhaps
went too far in that direction but
that's that that was basically a very
good thing he's his desire always to
push I'm often amazed actually looking
at Microsoft he's on the one hand you
read a lot of stuff about how they're
you know they have an entrenchment up
early as old okay that's you know we the
Connors we've been critical a lot of
that but the other thing about that
Microsoft is their transparently not a
lazy company they had this force
pushing them and pushing and pushing
them to try and do more stuff and that
type of ability i think is terribly
important and you in them and that I
think is still the sort of core water to
leading because at the moment that there
is a vast amount of people who know how
to run things in a basic straightforward
way but it's the ability to be able to
be contrarian the fittest appealed to
suddenly think that one thing which can
shift directions that is dramatically
that really sets the very very good
people out from the normal ones think of
how many business leaders you'd want to
read a book about in this precise moment
there's not there's not not law that
many